in what is pivotal crucial to our
Constitution and that is a quest for
equal justice under the law equal
application of our laws it involves
numerous issues Julian Assange versus
Hillary Clinton and the great injustice
in the Roger stone case there in the
stone case a travesty of justice we have
all the details tonight and an insane
judge in that particular case plus we
will have reaction and analysis to the
very latest news from the Democrats
latest nasty bare-knuckle brawl
political night fight it was another
shift show
oh and yeah farmer Bloomberg admitting
oh yeah I try I bought the house of
representatives for Pelosi great move
but first breaking only moments ago big
news for Republicans eight elected
officials in minute Mississippi have
announced they are switching from
Democrats and independents to the
Republican Party now the Mississippi GOP
expects that more announcements will
follow soon also breaking tonight
more good news look at this in the state
of Kentucky special election and
Republican just won a state House
District that has been in Democratic
control since the 1980s this is a
preview of coming attractions
major news potential barometer for
things to come full an election analysis
is only moments away tonight but we do
start with bolshevik Bernie Sanders who
just can't seem to help himself
well now the Democratic frontrunner is
doubling down on his effusive praise of
communism sure
Castro murdered tens of thousands of his
own citizens he locked up political
dissidents confiscated private property
outlawed all freedoms and induced
widespread starvation and poverty but
according to Bolshevik Bernie Fidel
Castro's literacy program made it all
worth it
which is why literally hundreds of
thousands of Cubans let's see risk their
lives in broken-down rickety dilapidated
boats and shark-infested waters and
inner tubes in the hopes of getting here
and thankfully many did take a look a
lot of folks in Cuba at that point who
are literate and he formed the literacy
brigade you may remember read that we
went out and they help people learn to
read
and right you know what I think keep
teaching people to read and write is a
good thing I have been extremely
consistent and critical of all
authoritarian regimes all over the world
including Cuba including Nicaragua
including Saudi Arabia including China
including Russia now this is now the
second straight day Bolshevik Bernie has
gone out of his way praising Castro's
communist dictatorship my toy is awful
awful there we go perfectly anyway and
for what a propaganda filled free
education program masquerading as a
literacy platform now either Bolshevik
Bernie is incredibly stupid or he thinks
we the people are incredibly stupid his
radical brand of Soviet style socialism
is about one thing one thing only that
is government control and takeover of
every aspect of our lives now in every
socialist hellhole from Venezuela to
Cuba to the USSR his honeymoon place the
process is always the same and it all
starts with the nationalization of major
industry and promises oh the government
is going to give everyone everything for
free we're going to take care of
everything for you yeah well that's what
the new Green Deal is all about that's
what medicare-for-all is all about and
Bolshevik Bernie is literally plotting a
government takeover of two of America's
largest industries and make no mistake
this could easily cost over a hundred
trillion dollars in the next ten years
but don't worry
Bernie has a plan to cover the cost and
you're all going to pay for it
today he actually rolled out nine that's
right nine brand-new tax hikes for all
of you to enjoy and by the way here's
what the fake news media will ignore to
start anybody that makes twenty nine
thousand dollars a year is going to get
slapped with a four percent tax increase
next employers will get hit with an
additional 7.5 percent payroll tax by
the way they'll pass that on to we the
consumers high-income earners they're
going to now get taxed at a top federal
rate of 52 percent that's a 15 percent
hike their capital gains that'll go
through the roof by the way the death
tax
after you paid taxes after they steal
more money with his wealth tax and when
you die he's gonna take 77% as a top
rate Wow
they tax you again you have to pay to
die in America Inc the corporate income
tax rate will go up to 35% a 14-point
increase a new cap on itemized tax
deductions will be imposed the oil and
gas industry will be hit with a three
trillion dollar tax increase wonder what
they're gonna do with the price of oil
and gas I guess we're gonna pay that too
and last but not least large
corporations of Bernie's choosing will
get hit with a brand-new two trillion
dollar tax now that will be a recipe for
economic disaster those corporations are
not stupid they are going to leave this
country and take their business
elsewhere as will billionaires and
millionaires they are not going to give
their wealth over to Bernie Sanders and
his Bolshevik Revolution by the way it
still doesn't quite account for the
trillions in new spending and laughably
now Bolshevik Bernie's campaign is
claiming that as insane programs will
magically create 20 million new jobs
well he's just saying the other night
that we're gonna lose jobs under his
plan and by the way he's also claiming
there will magically save the government
trillions of dollars and that that will
make up the funding gap I know he's old
so he may not have a calculator yet
maybe somebody can update his abacus and
give poor Bernie a new calculator maybe
buy him an iPhone or something because
his math won't ever add up but tonight I
do have to hand it to Bernie from his
unyielding praise of communism bragging
about oppressive new taxes well he is at
least slightly more honest than his
opponents medicare-for-all green New
Deal late term abortions elimination of
the Second Amendment open borders free
health care for illegal immigrants
oh we not only have sanctuary cities but
a sanctuary country they all pretty much
want the same thing all of these
Democrats they are all radical extreme
socialists Bolshevik Bernie's raw candor
about the radical Democratic Party's
platform is making them a little nervous
just don't tell everybody this is what
we think they know the American people
won't buy it so now figuratively well
they are speaking out against Bernie
take a look you've had six national
elections two Democrat since 1990 to
have won the majority why you would take
that playbook has succeeded not once
six times throw it out and try something
not Center left but just left that's
what it makes no sense these positions
will be caricatured by Trump and I think
that what a lot of Democrats are saying
is that a Bernie Sanders nomination puts
the house at risk
it sounds pretty crazy but I listed two
on 60 minutes he was right on but has
there been communist regime that Bernie
Sanders visited that he didn't find
something appealing but there is nothing
groovy about a dictator now these
radical unapologetic socialist views are
not the only concern inside the
Democratic Party well now we're seeing a
tax of about his gross disturbing
articles in the case of Bolshevik Bernie
from the 70s now this includes what we
showed you last night where Bernie
openly fantasizing about a gang rape in
a piece that he wrote for alternative
newspaper tonight we have now uncovered
another article to show you by the way
viewer warning it is just this sick and
creepy is what we told you about last
night
this piece 1969 Sanders writing quote
now if children go around naked well
they are liable to see each other's
sexual organs and maybe even touch them
terrible thing we raise children up like
this that will probably ruin the whole
pornography business his words not mine
by the way he's a grown adult man and he
wrote that something wrong with this guy
like creepy Joe like Mike Bloomberg
today by the way the surprise of fake
news CNN is that a Bloomberg advisor
actually highlighted Bernie's bizarre
writings let's take a look at that Bruni
has all of this loopy stuff and his
background saying things like you know
women get cancer from having too many
orgasms or toddlers should run around
naked and touch each other's genitals to
insulate themselves from porn
why has this stuff not been more
surfaced he's written about women's rape
fantasies that has
and surfaced that's the loony side of
Bernie all right as Bloomberg really
care about any of this probably not but
his campaign is happy to deflect from
what was the worst debate performance in
American political history by the way he
came in with prepared lines and they
fell flat tonight and he also talked
about oh I bought Congress I paid I
bought Congress Wow okay what about
ethics and what about let's see oh
that's not the right thing to do that's
okay just buy your seats he also wants
to deflect from some newly uncovered
audio involving him from 2016 where the
former mayor was more than happy to
trash Barack Obama how's this gonna go
over in the Democratic primary
especially when you add it to well we
only we only throw minority kids up
against the wall you know you Xerox a
copy say memo minority 16 to 25 you know
that's where we put all the cops because
that's where all the crime is and only
minority neighborhoods listen to this
latest one the second election I wrote a
great backhanded endorsement of Obama
saying I thought he hadn't done the
right
things that I think report and Romney
would be a better person doing that but
Romney did not stick with the values
they had not he was governor of
Massachusetts all right buckle up why
cuz the chaos and the Democratic Party
is now descending into what is a nasty
political civil war the likes of which
we may have never seen before